your makeup is insane you look gorgeous
I feel like ariana grande you know
you're also the star of this movie so
yay for you you know didn't mean you
don't need to feel like anyone else
tonight this is a big night for you
thank you for that reminder I am hey
Lulu he's my best friend
what does what does this feel like to be
here with the entire road shut down at
this premiere honestly don't know even I
am just nervous out of my biscuit brains
like I don't know how to feel to be
honest I honest I don't think I would
have been so nervous if it weren't for
the fact that my mom and dad and my two
aunts are here from Arizona I think that
like for some reason I really want to
make them proud oh my gosh I'm sure you
make them proud this movie is sort of
being called the next Fault in Our Stars
and that was a movie that made me cry my
face off so on a scale of one to ten
like how many tissues do we need to
bring
[Applause]
but I think it's a therapeutic cathartic
type of cry so we're hopefully at the
end do you feel better I wanted to
introduce myself I'm well moving six
feet apart at all times both know the
rules let me guess you're the kind of
guy that ignores the rules cuz it makes
you feel in control am i right you're
not wrong you think that's cute do you
think it's cute you and call working
together what is that like working with
big cole sprouse were you a fan of sweet
life with Zack & Cody I'm a fan of been
on friends nice I love that I love it
wasn't like working with you and and
where your process is sort of the same
because this is the serious story
actually that was the thing that I mean
I like a lot of things about coal like I
consider him a pal a friend and you know
a lot of time you don't get that is you
never know what to expect when you're
working with all these different actors
so I was really thankful for that and I
think we both cared so much about doing
the research necessary and doing
anything we possibly could to do justice
to these two people and the very real
situations that they're in and so I
think yeah being on that same page
obviously made working with him like
just feel good like I was never worried
about working with coal like that was
something that I was oh I always felt
safe in that you're wearing this awesome
hot pink suit tonight altura warrants it
is also your birthday and that's what I
want to ask you like is this the clothes
birthday party ever
yeah I told him I liked what I when I
found out about this oh wow I'm seeing
all these people starting I get
distracted a little bit oh my god Emily
oh my god
you look so good so I can ask you it
looks like students are a big trend
tonight oh my how hot is she okay go go
go
[Music]